Donc à partir de ces règles,
on va alors créer le type de robot qui peut appliquer ces règles.
Ici, vous voyez un robot qui peut grimper sur des blocs,
mais il peut aussi les soulever et les déplacer,
il peut modifier la structure sur laquelle il se trouve.
Mais avec ces règles,
on ne peut créer qu'un type de robot.
On peut imaginer plein de types de robots différents.
Par exemple, des robots capables de déplacer des sacs de sable
pour aider à construire des digues.
ou bien de robots capables de construire à partir de matériaux souples,
et de travailler ensemble pour consolider une immeuble écroulé.
Il s'agit des mêmes types de règles dans des robots différents.
Ou si, comme pour mon équipe, les fourmis sont pour vous une obsession,
alors peut-être pourrons-nous créer des robots pouvant escalader n'importe quoi,
incluant d'autres robots de leur tribu,
d'assembler des choses en utilisant leurs corps.
Une fois les règles comprises,
toutes les visions de types de robot deviennent possibles.
Pour revenir sur la plongée aux Bahamas,
on comprend plein de choses sur les bancs de poissons et leurs règles.
Si on invente les robots qui vont avec,
alors peut-être qu'un jour,
mon équipe et moi plongerons avec un banc de poissons de notre création.
Chacun des systèmes que je vous ai montrés
nous rapproche des outils mathématiques et conceptuels
qui nous permettront de créer notre version d'une puissance collective,
ce qui rendrait possible de nombreuses futures applications,
comme des robots constructeurs de digues contre les inondations
des colonies de robots-abeilles pollinisatrices,
des bancs de robots sous-marins surveillant les coraux,
ou encore, si on vise encore plus loin, programmer
des constellations de satellites.
Dans chacun de ces systèmes,
la capacité à comprendre comment concevoir les règles d'engagement
et à générer de bons comportements collectifs
devient la clé pour rendre ces visions possibles.
Donc, j'ai parlé de règles pour les insectes et les poissons,
et pour les robots,
mais qu'en est-il des règles qui gouvernent notre collectivité humaine ?
Et la dernière pensée avant de vous laisser
est que la science en soi-même
est une extraordinaire manifestation de l'intelligence collective,
mais contrairement aux magnifiques bancs de poissons que j'étudie,
je pense qu'il nous reste beaucoup à parcourir sur le chemin de l'évolution.
Donc en plus de mon travail sur la science des collectifs de robots,
je travaille aussi sur la création de robots et de règles
qui amélioreront notre propre collectivité scientifique.
Il y a une citation que j'adore :
celui qui pratique la science détermine ce que la science réalise.
Imaginez une société dans laquelle
on aurait des règles d'engagement
qui permettraient aux enfants de grandir en sachant
qu'ils peuvent devenir les techniciens du futur,
et aux adultes de croire
qu'ils ont la capacité de non seulement comprendre
mais aussi changer la manière dont la science influence leurs vies.
À quoi ressemblerait cette société ?
Je pense que c'est possible.
Je pense que l'on peut choisir nos règles,
concevoir non seulement des robots
mais aussi notre propre collectivité humaine.
Et quand cela sera rendu possible, ce sera merveilleux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)